you're you're big on saying marriage is
it only goes well when you have two
bathrooms right you have your own
bathroom yeah I I second this because I
don't know what it is about dudes why is
their hair everywhere yeah toothpaste
tops
it doesn't have to be the sink is no
it's a bit grandiose oh we need your own
bathrooms it just I'm all for man caves
girl caves yeah your own space go and
party with the hot rods in the garage go
plant a few herbs in the garden
yeah you know because it does it if you
spend any amount of time with anybody at
work you little space you know yeah but
I do for me the bathroom is more of a
sanctuary it's not just brushing my
teeth and brushing my hair you know it's
overtaking the candles it's the best
it's the creams it's the lotions it's
the salts you put and I feel much
happier after I come out there without
any intrusion yeah you can do whatever
you want yes
I'm 100 for this that's my sanctuaries
well I literally just redid mine because
I was like this is not good enough
because it's my like one place my little
kids I can lock them out of
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]